[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to Game of Thrones has just dropped
its second episode and it's pretty clear
that after a slightly slower season
premiere all of the big pieces are
finally falling into place
though this again felt like a lot of
self it's intriguing to see all of the
characters coming together and I'm
pretty stoked to see what will happen
down the line throughout this video I'll
be breaking down everything that you
need to know about episode 2 as well as
what it could lead to in episode 3 this
is full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
seen their latest release in the season
yet and don't want to know what happens
and then I highly recommend that you
turn off now without the way I hope you
enjoyed the video now sit back relax and
let's get into my ending explain
breakdown of Game of Thrones season 8
episode 2 okay so just a quick recap on
episode 1 the premiere of the season
felt like a big highschool reunion with
a lot of the cast of characters meeting
after many years apart
Cersei said something that will forever
be quoted by teenage girls on Instagram
Sam divulge to Jon that Daenerys is an T
which he insists his treason and Brian
had a week long staring contest with
Jaime Lannister episode 2 picks up
immediately after this with Jaime
arriving at Winterfell like the new kid
on campus none of the characters have
followed him for 7 seasons so they
kindly remember him as the bad guy from
primary school that you've been trying
to avoid your entire life because he
weds GG once it's clear that he's had a
change of heart though and early on
Jaime reminds us why we love him so much
by telling everyone that this goes
beyond loyalty and is about survival
Brienne vouches for him and because
Sansa vouches for Brienne he's quickly
accepted as the new hot guy in school
that everyone wants to sit with Jaime
pretty much goes through the episodes
setting things up for the future and we
get him venturing around the area
meeting the characters and trying to
show that he's the MVP if you like me
and thought that bran could be a bit mad
at him for well of pushing him out of a
window you'll be pleased to know that
there are no grudges held because one
Jaime is the new jock and bran needs the
cool points and two he has the ability
to see
time and it's probably been staring at
Jamie since season one so knows that
he's a changed man Jamie also catches up
with Tyrion to bash their sister and
reunites with Brienne to hash it out a
bit he ends up knighting her later in
the episode which is a nice little
conclusion of their arc together and all
the things they've been through area is
also looking at getting some loving
finally which no it's not creepy I know
she might seem like she's still 12 years
older than that yeah but I'm pretty sure
she's about 32 now so just let the girl
get some right it can't all be sex and
sisters though as the White Walkers are
slowly very very slowly walking towards
Winterfell and Dany meets up with Sansa
to mend bridges the two kind of discuss
what's happening and what will
eventually happen and it's clear that
Dany won't let the love for her nephew I
mean boyfriend get in the way of the
throne anyway they decide that the way
to attract a knight King is to lure him
out using bran
if you've seen my knight King explained
video which if you haven't go watch it
after this then you'll know that bran
has been mocked by the character and
therefore can be found by him at all
times they plan to use this to draw him
out and finally take him down though it
probably won't be that easy it's almost
like a prom party where all the
characters talk and there's even some
sex though we don't see any nudity which
if that's what you came for then this
will be the worst game of Thrones
episode ever anyway John has been
ghosting Danny since he found out she's
his auntie and has never once given him
her Christmas present and the to hash it
out and it becomes pretty clear that
John also has a claim to the throne
which would probably put him in the
firing line of Danny's favorite dragon
just as they're about to discuss who
will get the throne when this is all
over
they are Saved by the Bell literally and
the horns of war sound I pretty much
wrote this entire video as a high school
metaphor for that one Saved by the Bell
line and yeah it wasn't worth it I'm
sorry
anyway the knight King & Co are finally
here and there's about to be a big
showdown episode 3 is clearly going to
be the big battle that's been teased in
the trailers a man I really can't wait
for this huge showdown
Cersei didn't even need to be present in
this episode and their absence actually
makes you realise that she's going to be
absent for the fight going forward I
actually think that the mature
the forces will be slaughtered here as
from a writing point of view the golden
company needs to come in at some point
down the line so it makes sense that our
winterfell wonders will lose and would
be forced to team up with them in the
future it's going to make a great third
episode and a definitely thing that all
this setup will be worth it obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
episode and if you were disappointed by
the premiere did this restore your faith
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the first episode which would be
linked at the end I'm gonna be breaking
down every episode of Game of Thrones
week by week so make sure you stay
locked in to the channel for updates
every Monday this is the channel for
people who are never missing television
so if that's the kind of thing you like
you need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
you